hello and
welcome to our two hour fun for
tonight lessons i am dorothy directory
as you can see right below
uh ben simon is our producer tonight
we have my choice which is whoops sorry
which is one of my favorite classes and
also the games of the week i have a mini
surprise for you
for games of the week but i don't
anticipate it
to be too much of a surprise but
anyways any surprise is good right as
long as there's a cat
somewhere around it oh my god i really
wish you guys could see peachy right now
his like
hand they were here a leg over there is
like someone twisted into this little
cute
furball all right um
so for tonight i have some of the use of
puzzles that i really want to share he
is a great
um well just his books are amazing
so i think you can never have enough
yusuf
and um so that's one of the reasons that
most of the puzzles that you will see
tonight are from his books
and i will also share the link that i
have on leeches with you after we're
done with the puzzles
and uh then we're going to move on to
some
games that are from
this week well with a time machine
all right so um
please go ahead and let me know what you
think you should do in
the first one i am showing you this for
the purpose of
warming up your brain just a little bit
i'm hoping that this will be helping you
feel a little bit more confident in your
end game
when it comes to down wait comes down to
that because
so many of pawn end games are just
tricky
and you might easily miss the win
and it's you shouldn't so you should
have an easier time with pawn and games
so please feel free to just
i'm reading the chat from right here and
so please feel free to just
type in and let me know what you think
should be the first
move and we can take it from there
and one more thing before i
um give you a little time to think i'm
hoping you're actually thinking right
now
but make sure you take your time and
think about how to activate your pieces
how to stop
opponents pieces from activating how to
use your passport
and all those but uh unfortunately for
us lazy people who don't want to
calculate
is you should actually calculate in pawn
at games you can calculate
easier but they should still calculate
you should
uh keep in mind when you queen when he
queens
all right so i see something i see a
move in the chat
great um i think i'll give it maybe
another 30 seconds maybe a minute before
we jump into it
okay oh i see question marks
like me like so uh king b4
will only lead to a draw because king
will go to e5
king c5 now the king is closer now a5
kind of wraps it up and goes to dc
careful not king d4
because then push pawn just kind goes to
d6 and this
will be a draw because c5 just king
gets to go back you take and we know how
to draw this
right just wait and this is a draw
so for this reason king b4 is not the
move
you should go king to d4
now if king d4 um
anybody want to tell me how to continue
after that
let's say king goes to f5 now what do
you do
um well we should bring up the king yes
it's important not to go to c5 it's very
important to play this king to d5
because king d5 you should keep this
king
cut and don't allow it hello from mexico
thank you mexico is one of the countries
i've always wanted to go and
every time i wanted something came up so
that's as a little
i'm glad that hopefully that's after
kobet i can just
travel a little anyways king f6 king d6
you should keep the king cut that's
crucial if you push now the king gets to
go and
stop you so as long as you're keeping
this king cut
white is winning now if king f7
now you can push because if king goes to
e8 i can just even play king c7 and
a5 c6 just move my king and
make this queen with check which is one
of our goals in pawn end games you
should be very
aware of giving by promoting with check
and you win what if black pushes where
do you think
if you're talking about here if black
pushes
a5 you can just simply play a
c4 sorry c5 c6 if a3 now your king is
well within
the square right so
your king can just join in and stop the
pawn
yep and if after king goes to f5 king d5
the problem is that when you make a
queen it will be with check so if you
were to play a5 i'll just push
i'll just push push
and it becomes queen with czech
yes france lovely i've only passed
through france i never actually get
got the chance to visit the country well
technically i was in corsica
so i guess that counts just a little bit
but
my mom is a huge fan of corsica she
is completely mesmerized by napoleon has
always been so
i kind of grew up with that mindset as
well
all right any other questions for this
specific endgame
if not i would be more than happy to
move along from this one
all right i think everybody are doing
good
okay so i'm not
looking at this with the intentional
opponent game sorry i think i
jumped ahead a little too much yes this
is the one i want
um we are looking at these with the
intention of warming up our brain just a
little bit
because i want to be able to um
show you more of the middle game
joshua i i understand your point of view
but my mom would not
she would probably be giving you a very
scary stare
that you would not be able to handle it
what do you guys think on this one
it is white to move so when you see this
position
what do you like what's the first thing
that's kind of popping up in your head
i'd rather be white here too so i said
the idea with king d6
to be fair if it was just king d6 i
wouldn't give you this puzzle right
so trying trying yeah making this
triangle i
i said triangulation but i don't think
that's the right force
making the triangle is the first thing
that should come in your mind
because um well
okay so it's easier to do that
because can d6 makes sense but the
problem is that the king d6 is your
ultimate goal
but the problem is king c8
and it makes a little harder because now
you have to play like
in c5 he goes to c7
and if you do king d5 this still works
but if you're if you're not working with
the idea of triangle if you just play c7
not just a4
and a5 and now this is a draw
so as long as you're working with the
idea of doing this triangle you will
most likely find the right or
the right way king c4 is one of the
easiest way now if you play king c8 king
d4
if you go to d8 boom d5
you go king c8 king d6 because now if
you play a4
i can just take it and then i can play
c7 you gotta move the king and then i
get to make a queen
um so
king c4 king d4
and yeah that's kind of the easiest way
to try
and do this
any questions on it the main idea of
this puzzle
was to do this triangle so as long as
you found that you did great
all right i'm gonna move ahead what
about this one this is a slightly more
challenging not everybody should still
be good on this
ah thank you shams i like being your bus
teacher
okay hello chess king hello everybody
okay i think you guys are
finding it yes okay eight is the best
one because if you take king b7
the trick is if you take it when i take
you see that's why pawn and games matter
so much because you have to know your
pawn end games to be able to find these
little tricks of rk8 or something like
that
now if king comes up you just bring the
king
king g6 king c6 see he win the
opposition the long opposition
in d7 king d6 these are
the the mint squares or the pin at the
or like the the bomb squares you if you
get in here
depending on whose move it is um
that's gonna you shouldn't so if right
now it was vitamin white would be
in a pickle if it was black same with
black would be in a pickle
so yeah
and if you just didn't do that again a8
and
even though the king is too far do you
think we can still make this work
and white still win this what do you
guys think about this pawn end game
i'll give you guys maybe um a minute
just to
wrap it up make sure you get the point
of the puzzle
all right most people are saying white
wine is great some people are
still figuring out if uh white twins or
black wins
all right so i think uh white you are
correct white has it
um so
if king goes to g7 we bring the king we
bring the king and again we
reach the same position now if black
were to play something with king f7
and then go e7 again we win the
opposition
and again we are doing great so
yeah what do you guys think any thoughts
on this or should i move ahead
move along yeah
all right i think everybody is doing
good so let's go ahead
and we are almost done with our end game
section
segment there we go started off with end
game we're gonna go
back to middle game
so why to move be very careful because
if you lose this pawn the game is kind
of over
or is it if you could strategically kind
of give it up
and maybe try to get a checklist that's
another way
so you have a bunch of ideas but it's
really important to try and actually
understand them
do
all right so i see a lot of great ideas
are coming up
most of you so far are in favor of
knight e2 which is the best move
uh knight e4 is also doable because you
stop this but thinking goes to f5
and then you would probably have to like
do a knight d2 to cut over here that
king goes to f4
and it's a little hard to actually be
able to win it you could try to bring
the king back but then again king goes
to f4
so it's it makes your life a little too
hard and slash miserable so don't do
that
make sure you just do the good moves do
then i teach you
cut the king if the king goes to f3 now
i see the idea with knight g1 and i like
it
king g2 now um king e4 chess king you
are correct
you do manage to come king i would still
recommend king f3 because if king f4
now there's king f2 winning the
opposition if king g4
now the king kind of gets behind your
pawn so be careful with these
little moves but you did have the right
idea so good job
and now this is a win for white right
easy peasy win pushed upon kabul
any questions on this
okay i'm gonna move along if there are
any questions don't
just let me know so
we are moving a little bit more to the
middle game
segment so um take as much as time you
need and
give me a full line just as chess king
just did that was great thank you
um well to me to be completely honest
i um patterns are easier for me to spot
that to actually calculate them
and that's one of the things that i am
working on to improve because i want to
be able to
calculate as fast as i see the patterns
so right now with this king here and the
fact that i don't have a point one of
the things that comes to mind design
man i really wish i could do like a
background checkmate so that's one thing
that could potentially be interesting
um another thing because of this how
strong this
this pawn is and
the other thing is well
i really have to be careful because if i
don't do anything my rook is
falling so i might have to work on that
too
um
i think the problem of rook h1 is simply
bishop takes e5
or something like queen d5 and your
pieces are
not exactly placed ideally so
we can't really do that um chess king
has it chess king is correct
you bring up your rook and then you give
this check
and now you took this crucial square
away from the king no more king running
and now you give this checkmate
i feel like this is like a little
advanced puzzle rush
type hopefully
alright so let's keep going uh this one
is black to move
this one should also be easy i would
like
lines just as chess king just did that
would be amazing
or if you are a super certain of your
line feel free to just give like the
first two moves of it
i'm if you do the first two moves
correct i'm sure you
i can trust that you have the rest of it
correct too
all right i see you guys are kind of
okay i think you guys are doing good yes
thank you zippo
oh barcelona i like barcelona
yes rookie one is the best one if you
would knight f1
and yes again you can simply
sorry do this check i was thinking this
is another checkmate
it's kind of fun too um but so
what if check king goes up now what
zeppel has it is rh1 because again your
knights can't move because g2 falls
and if your king moves again this cool
idea with overloaded
and pinned material so one thing that
you could do
right here when you see the position
first i
can assume some people might have a
little
uncertainty when it comes to this
position is
that your strongest piece is your bishop
right
that's kind of already going after g2
and
you should be careful because there is
an attack on your king
just as well but the point is that your
opponent doesn't really have any
effective check
right now so it gives you the luxury of
having the first check
so it's kind of the idea thank you luca
to figure out how to make this work
and the other thing that should come to
mind is okay i have a check
okay that's that's another collaboration
by just
seeing these ideas you sh you can easily
find the right move um
and yeah as long as you see the check
you see this g2
being super attacked you're good
all right what about this position
again try to identify those patterns
trying to
identify where like try to picture
the weak square try to picture how the
mates should be achieved and then you
can actually get it
all right i see everybody is kind of
beginning to
see at least the patterns okay so i've
seen easily the idea of bishop f6 queen
h6
queen f6 these are kind of coming up
hello peter
but the problem is this king being able
to run to g8 when you give them this
check
so that's something that you could
potentially work on
uh maybe let me try and ask you a
question
ah thank you we just got the right
answer i was just going to ask you what
do you think is this night actually
attacking you helping your attack
or not because if it's not then yes
exactly as two people are just saying it
96
get rid of the knight when he takes it
now give this check
well if the king goes to g8 you have
checkmates if the king takes it you have
a beautiful checkmate with the bishop
just as well
yeah um this one was still uh
kind of doable but you had to find some
lines first
and then realize that your your knight
was blocking your bishop and then you
had to get rid of it
so that was cool the other thing just to
mention is if the king goes down again
queen b8
the background checkpoints exist it is
so funny
one of my students she's like six years
old she's so cute and
she sometimes has trouble eating like
the free
free material in front of her but she's
amazing at background checkmate like
she's so good she says it's a little
faster than i do she's like constantly
looking for that
so i'm trying to teach her to actually
do the same thing and constantly look
for if there's anything free to eat
what piece to activate stuff like that
and
i think it's blank all right but she's
still amazing at background checkmates
other type of checkmates i still have to
like poke her be like hey
maybe tell me where your checks maybe
let's just look at all the possible
checks
hello elvis don't worry we still have a
lot of puzzles to go
a lot of fun ones you kind of you kind
of skip the boring ones you're good
okay i see you guys are actually very
great at this
all right i see everybody is warming up
to this idea amazing
i didn't really have to throw in any
hands too knight f5 f7 great
the point is that you're not exactly
looking for checkmate you're looking for
peace activity and you take
you easily take and now your bishop is a
little monster
and a rook eater right
i like that i like having a monster
bishop and a rook eater
um nothing else really works after a
knight f7 simple idea it's a
fork and you can't really do that yeah
it's a little decoy puzzle yeah
i'm glad you guys like it what about
this one
this one should be easy for most people
because it's
more straightforward you don't really
need to get rid of any piece to open
square for any other piece
it's not crazy stuff like that
i can tell you it's checkmate in five
yes chess king you are correct queen h7
to be sure also works
all right i see everybody is warming up
to it
they're finding it i'm loving it let's
go
uh queen g7 is the best one because
after take you simply take back
here and you're kind of forming this
really
killer move and the
big thing is this bishop controlling f8
so king goes to g8 rook g7 check
and come back here checkmate good job
you guys
what about this one does this inspire
you
to eat something to give some sort of
checks
still looking okay i'm getting some cool
um check answers so
maybe bishop f7 let's say uh king f7
then what do you do
nice one peter yeah we persians don't
just take a piece we take it all
i have the same attitude with chocolate
too and
cookies and kebab generally with food
or money
interesting i'm learning new things
about myself yes
good job guys take thank take take take
the queen kaboom
i like that this one went pretty fast
thank you everybody for your cooperation
ah this one is black to move this one
should also be super easy i'll give you
guys
one minute this is like a real puzzle
rush right here
make sure you're thinking about your
checks
all right you guys got it yep check take
first make sure to take it and
kaboom yeah this one is an easy one just
the main thing was to just be a little
cautious
about the move order because sometimes
people get a little confused and they
like you give the check and then you
forget and you give the other check
all right you guys are perfect what
about this one
this one when you see it you should
immediately be like oh my
there's a queen i change but i can't do
that because he takes over here
so i wish some of these people would
take my rook so i could give that
checkmate
i think that kind of helps it
all right i see some really great ideas
coming along
i think we're almost ready to
all right i see a lot of you are saying
your kablooms
i will not go on twitch anymore tonight
but we have classes tomorrow on twitch
all right queen f6 is the best one
indeed if you take it he will just
simply take back to be fair you still
do hold a minor advantage but it's
nothing big anymore
so queen f6 is the best one because
you're threatening checkmate and
he has to take over here and done
checkmates
what about this one this one should also
be easy as
long as you find the um
the right move it's not a hard move it's
just
a matter of taking away some squares
threatening some full
[Music]
stuff
you
i still have a4s
i think euroslav has it champs got it
all right guys you guys are getting it
yeah so
um technically here you could play g5
and
it's like still much much better for
black
but the problem is that you still have
to see
this move on rook d3 a gpa is not
pointless rook d3 is the best one
i was just making a point that's not the
only one
um so rook
d3 the fun thing is if you take it boom
that's the most beautiful mate ever if
you don't take it there's another boom
coming up that you can't stop if you
play something like roxy one
i have so many different ways to mate
you it's just funny at this point
so sorry let me also highlight this
so yeah i think this is a very beautiful
puzzle thank you yusuf
for this i uh brian smith
i am not wearing a tiara i wish i was
but tiara's
make me uncomfortable it just feels like
if i don't have a country to rule i
don't want to wear a tiara
yeah i don't think having a cat to rule
counts
also let me take that back he's the one
bossing me around or rolling and
trolling me
so never mind
okay i see you guys are finding it good
job yeah after having solved the
previous puzzle this should be too easy
just check if you take kaboom if don't
take
then we have queen c2 i feel like the
last times we
don't we did a lot of still mate so i
like these because they're
kind of forceful but previously
previously we did forceful four still
mate
now we're doing forceful for mates so i
kind of like these more
uh we have i have about um
a little over 10 actually like 13 more
that i'm hoping to get to so if you guys
could um
collaborate with me and we do this next
13 minutes
13 in next 20 minutes we'll be awesome i
think we can make it
and then we'll switch to
our time machine
yes you guys got it you're very fast r8
is the best one
well you have to take it and now i'll
just eat your queen uh the funny thing
is kidney 7 you would still lose the
queen
good good great here's a very fast i
love it
what about this one this should be a
little bit more
[Music]
challenging
so
i like this the chat is thinking it's
taking you guys a full minute
or two yay ah and the first answer was
actually
not correct whoa
this is great haha guys be careful
night and there's a knight here that's
protecting a1
you can't just go and throw that throw
away your knight
um your stuff i think you have the um
you're thinking about it somewhat
correctly but that's not the right move
i like this puzzle it's good to chat to
think actually
oh
nice one petey niace could you please
elaborate
more on your idea
so
the chat is so quiet so you guys gave me
some checks it didn't work let's move on
to takes
yeah nice goddess i please let me know
if i'm
mispronouncing the username because
sometimes that happens more than i like
it
so yeah taking is the easiest but that
the idea of this puzzle is for you to
realize that
right now your attack doesn't work the
best thing you can do with your attack
is gain some material out of it
and go on a simpler end game and try
your chances there
so you're going to take over here give
that check give another check
and now you have
this beautiful position you're at the
end ethan e42
and you have what two more pawns uh it's
good enough to have a very comfortable
end game
so that's that was the point of this
puzzle to realize that
even though your position looks like it
has something you know queen and bishop
knight over here two rooks over here it
actually doesn't
and knight a3 does not work it's simply
winning for white now
you can just play c file and get away
with it
so yeah good job guys all right any
question on this
if there are any questions let me know
and we can always come back
so again i think the main question here
is does your attack work
if it does what do you think is the best
move here
uh
i see a lot of knight g4s but do you
think that 94 actually works
because my g4 i could just run look like
chasing me
all right so i think we agree this is
not the most efficient way
yeah discover it's like thank you nice
check check boom eat the queen another
another thing that i really want to
point out in this type of positions is
um if you could sharpen your
um your senses your chest senses
into immediately identifying the pieces
that are kind of hanging this queen here
is hanging you can't really
uh the screen is kind of defenseless so
if you could that's kind of the whole
basis of
your um check check ethan the queen type
of deal
so that's why you should be very
uh cautious of these because again
that's something that's going to come up
a lot in your
chess career or just any type of chess
that you play doesn't need to be a
career
um you have to be able to uh identify in
pretty much immediately where is the
dropping pieces what pieces are
defenseless
same with like outposts same with like
where are my checks
and i feel like whenever i say well
where are my checks i
have a feeling when like daenerys
targaryen and game of thrones was
screaming where are my dragons
so if that helps you why not
all right i see some bishop h6 ideas
i'll see some knight type six ideas uh
to be fair i think both of it works but
one of it is definitely better than the
other now which one do you think is
better
um
well the problem is bishop h6 it's not
as efficient because
take if you give this check the problem
is bishop g7 and there it is
f5s that then the queen can defend the
bishop even if you do knight f6 just
king goes
at f8 you give check can go to g8
you try to bring up the queen there's f5
that's kind of going to um
help your opponent instead of you
so you don't want this queen to be
activated
that's why knight f6 is the better
choice because it cuts the queen
permanently
if you take it now it's made in three
check king goes away
rook g3 and no way to stop this
and if after check the king goes to h8
now you can take it over here
right yeah i think good job elvis
now if you take it again i can even do
like clean up here and attack that
checkmate that's the easiest way
that's the most efficient way because if
you went queen g4
again there's bishop g7s and then you
have to do like a knight e8 and then
there's f5s
you don't want to give your opponent
chances to um
get away with it anyway so uh the other
point was if you can usually take if not
take knight goes to d7
it's super easy i would probably just
play queen h5 because that makes the
most sense to me
if you take it just bishop g7 and
check that should be made super shortly
um and if you do that uh but in the game
they i think bishop g7 was recommended
because now
there's like this cool queenish file and
then this trick is coming
and it's just super cool checkmate too
we will be attaching this link the link
to the studies after we're done with
this
what about this one let's try and
squeeze in few more
all right there's some interesting stuff
coming thank you
that's undefended that should come in
handy hopefully
um what else
um
all right so i see a lot of interesting
ideas especially with bishop h6
and i think you guys are correct to be
fair this rook d6
first also works and then you cannot
follow up with either knight f5
or taking over here uh but it's not the
strongest one the strongest one is
bishop h6 first
check them check and you are
going after multiple checkmate ideas
and now if he tries to go back boom
knight f5
going after checkmates uh and
here kind of the end of it yeah
any questions
our humans are doing great especially
with the um
sorry with identifying the weak pieces
and the checks you're
doing great
f7 pawn is kind of the key and this
bishop was a monster
all right let's try to finish up strong
this one is a good one
all right you guys get it yeah i think
yourself has the
right idea i'll give it another minute
so everybody's caught up
i see more ideas coming in thank you
ellie thank you shams
yeah let's go for it take take check
take you guys
and the idea is very simple checkmate's
coming up you would have to give up your
queen
and that is not a very pleasant position
you want to be in
um maybe let's try one more just one
more and then we can happily
uh switch to the next one
this one is a little bit more
challenging than the previous one
but it's you still should have an easy
time finding it
make sure you're thinking about your
checks and takes
okay
it's kind of cool nobody has so far
managed to
come up with ideas i like this
oh all right we i see one idea
maybe we can try to get more into it
thank you nice yes taking is the best
one
and after take take queen h3 and the
problem is bishop f3 is coming up
what if you play e4 what now
yep you bring your rook you go after
disco
the fun part is something like we need
to also doesn't work because
check and this drops and then that also
drops with another check
and that before well never mind that
we're gonna this is
another great check uh one more thing to
consider
is if you played like queen to c2 that
was something that i was thinking about
is still check works again take it's
kind of funny because well if you play
like king d3 again queen h3
so you don't exactly have to win the
queen to get the mates
and if you go king e3 i think even queen
h6 give the check win the queen
is another easy way and i believe that
is the link for the study please double
check and let me know if it works or not
and i'm gonna go um
get ready for the next one i should be
back in about
five or seven minutes depending on how
long
my coffee takes to be honest um but
please hang around go go grab a coffee
tea
snacks and be back in about five minutes
for
our games of the week and i have a mini
surprise for you
because we are talking about the games
of this week
but not this year so that should be fun
right
thank you ben i will see you guys in
about five
ish minutes